let's jump into this first story maybe
we'll talk about the hurricane in a bit
from timgas.com two explosions
registered near nordstream pipelines
causing gas to leak in Baltic Sea a
senior Ukrainian official accused Russia
of the explosions calling them an act of
terrorism now you may have noticed we
titled this show us accused and that's
because online what you're seeing pop up
all over Twitter and on social media is
a video of Joe Biden saying that the U.S
was going to take this action I think
it's it's obvious that Russia is being
accused of doing this but my issue right
there is we could we could we could
structure the story and frame it a
certain way we can say U.S accused which
we chose to do we could say Russia
accused which I feel kind of makes no
sense or we could say both U.S and
Russia separately accused of of state of
engaging in sabotage the issue I take
with this is that if Russia were to have
been the one that detonated explosion
that detonated some device blowing up
the pipeline it's a false flag attack
and I don't think that's the simple
solution